hello and welcome to scale up your
security telemetry this is an time
tracking with Google Cloud and Chronicle
I want to highlight some of the
challenges and some of the solutions
that organizations face in their battles
to optimize and improve their security
operations and improve threat detection
I want to start with trying to give a
bit of a landscape around threats
security operations and highlight some
of the things that matter today a lot of
the things we encounter in this space
are artifacts of the past errors we have
to deal with issues that I've inherited
by companies and that have been dealt
with for years
however they're also new things that our
predecessors doing security operations
have not seen I also wanted to highlight
the role of the cloud as both something
to to monitor somewhere to detect
threats in and also an enabler for
modern security operations and the next
I wanted to cover the details around
Chronicle the modern security analytics
platform that gathers some of the
advantages of the cloud to enable you
detect threats in both on-premise and
cloud environments afterwards I want to
highlight some of the practical
recommendations that you can follow
whether you are a chronicle customer or
not now why do so many security
presentations start from a threat
landscape to me I do that because I want
to get on the same page with everybody I
wanted to highlight some of the things
we see with other organizations and some
of the challenges you face today now
every security presentation that I've
seen almost everyone I've seen in my
entire career starts on a discussion of
badness
maybe hackers and children breaches
crime where the words may change but the
approach does not ultimately the
security profession is driven by the
threat we are driven by what the bad guy
is trying to throw at us in that sense
security is unique domain of knowledge a
lot of the things we do in security are
quite different to what's done in IT
because much of what we do is about
dealing with what an outsider a threat
actor or malware is about to throw this
way why is it like this what are some of
the things would happen in the near
future now some of you may think hey
it's a pain for the obvious question
this is a domain of security we protect
against hackers attackers malware all
that however
there's actually a specific reason in my
opinion as to why it's the case now our
world unfortunately looks like this this
is my very unscientific visual that
shows changes in the number of security
analysts security engineers security
professionals in general and the amount
of staff amounts of technology that
needs securing think those are you
starting a security career many years
ago probably remember the time when you
have to secure secure servers in a data
center maybe web servers maybe file
servers and essentially nothing else
this was perhaps in the late 90s or
maybe even before that for some of the
more enlightened ones of you now today
we face a very dizzying array of
technologies to secure from well the
same servers going all the way back to
mainframes and technologies that predate
servers going all the way back to 80s or
maybe 70s but we also have cloud
computing mobility we have Internet of
Things we have all the analytics
pipelines we have the emergent AI we
have a lot of technologies within the
domain of digital technology spanning IT
and ot operational technology control
systems and IOT Internet of Things in
essence what we have today and we expect
to continue having this is that the
number of technologies systems things to
secure would keep growing and most
everybody agrees that it would keep
growing faster than the number of
security people so many of the
challenges with breaches badness alert
overload NIST attacks stem from the fact
that we just don't have enough people so
what can possibly be done to help it you
can automate things but we'll we'll
touch on this but the problem is that
this is belief this is the world we live
in and in this world we do have an
increasing amount of things they have a
secure how do we ever hope to win the
battle we'll talk about now in the
presentation
people talk about threats and today I
wanted to kind of offer my own spin on
this and say these are popular security
incident types now admittedly in recent
years ransomware have become a big thing
and it's been good number of years since
it became a scourge that it is now
phishing attacks continue to be a big
part of the modern security incidents if
you look at any industry reports that
cover items that were involved in
breaches and attacks fishing was always
always almost always make an appearance
now the data theft
whether it's payment date a valuable
corporate data private citizens data is
still there while ransomware is a type
of malware we still see a fair number of
other malware you know web malware
traditional viruses and Trojans you know
of service attacks continue to be
interested in and this is the type of
attacks I've dealt with in my past life
as an analyst the interesting did about
this is that while some considered to be
a nuisance others considered to be
considered now service to be a business
killing attack now to me I hesitate when
I put inside the threats on any kind of
a top top popular list of attacks
I do see organizations that are deeply
concerned with insider threat and this
may be well in the cloud or on-premise
inside of it continues to be more of a
low burning issue for some but there are
organizations that are quite heavily
focused on insider threats so I wanted
to kind of highlight as number six my
unauthorized access and inside the
threat challenges so to me this is the
list of things that keeps modern chief
security officers asleep at night or
maybe nervous during the day now there
may be other threats and issues that
meat that you deal with in your business
or in your industry but these are kind
of top popular issues and if I are doing
the monitoring if you are doing security
operations planning you're probably
focusing somewhere on these issues
now the spectrum of attacks does go all
the way up and of course there are rare
but highly damaging attacks all the so
called state-sponsored or just top-tier
cybercrime actors there is a type of a
threat that it shows up in well in the
news for sure sometimes in mean
in organizational security monitoring
dashboard but threats that for example
target Google going back many years ago
many of them are top two your threats so
well we talk about popular threats the
reason I want to show this slide is
while you may fight malware every day
you it will probably be useful it'll
probably be useful to keep aware of the
top tier threat actors that have very
much human and not automated and not
automated systems that can be good at
computers and at people in essence when
you focus on popular threats don't
forget that there is a type of a threat
that may affect your organization's
that's very far out or up from that
statue this reminder would help us to
contextualize some of the security
analytics requirements we'll get to now
security operations challenges
specifically challenges that socks deal
with very often focus on these things I
highlighted in this slide now if you
recall this slide with a visual with my
with my linear graph you do realize that
keep acquiring and keeping talented
people to do security operations is
challenging now there are many many
other things that come up
obviously this the growth of spectrum
technology is complexity of IT mixture
of new and old IT edition of ot and IOT
all puts additional stress to security
operations now number five on that slide
is kind of self-inflicted because in
many cases in my in my experience
security teams and security operations
teams aren't really friends with some IT
operations teams now at mature
enlightened organizations they are but
in some of the mainstream organizations
they are not think patching think asset
management think DevOps challenges
security and IT does have an occasional
friction point to me it is important to
consider when you're playing in threat
detection and monitoring those security
operations now one thing to note is that
many of these challenges are similar at
least philosophically conceptually
similar to what we had five or ten years
ago but they're definitely bigger
there's a lot more IT there's a lot more
security tools because there are more
alerts and there's a lot more of the
opinion that you should deploy the
latest technology rather than to refine
and improve what
I think that's enough of the landscape
frankly I think that I presented a few
slides here to kind of get on the same
page with the audience in terms of what
an organization may deal with now
cloud computing by the way as I promised
highlights and shows up as both
something to monitor systems in deployed
in the cloud micro services other cloud
components but also as a enabler of
security monitoring that's where we get
to Chronicle now you may not like
another challenges slide but I wanted to
present this particular visual to kind
of highlight the comparison between how
Chronicle security analytics platform is
built versus some of the existing tools
I can call them legacy I would say in IT
security if something's more than 10
years old it's definitely legacy the
idea is some of the technologies that
were born before the cloud are a little
bit difficult to scale or they may scale
physically but they would not scale
economically and at the same time there
are always challenges with to limit
telemetry types of data being incomplete
now when we are deploying a security
monitoring tool in 2020 we would be
seeing things that didn't exist five
years ago ten years ago and to me this
is this matters because I want to focus
on detecting the popular trends but also
I want to focus on detecting in modern
threats
I want my security analytics platform to
grow with threats and I think that's
occasionally missing from the
traditional tools so enough of that I
want to go deeper into Chronicle to
highlight some of the advantages of our
approach now many companies many
organizations deploy with a mission
statement or with a high level vision
many of them are somewhat generic I
wanted to brief up briefly point at the
chronicle vision of building a plane and
scale system for storing and analyzing
enterprise telemetry and making it
useful for detection hunting in response
now this to me is very crisp and to me
when I joined Chronicle and an
ultimately Google cloud that was a big
part of the of appeal because to me as
an analyst I wanted to look at
that scale with scale economically it
cover modern use cases can cover
traditional use cases and can also cover
many of the security operations
challenges detecting nowadays threat
hunting is pointing to issues so to me
this is a way to do that Chronicle to me
is a way to build as modern security
analytics platform rather than just to
try evolved in a sim slowly that matters
some of you in the audience they have
deployed security information event
management tools or sims for a good
number of years and there's a long
history of fairly challenging deployment
scenarios as we as we learn from
previous slide I wanted to build we
wanted to build a platform that's easy
that's deployable and it does you're
leveraged unique Google assets like
threat intelligence and of course search
speed no no debate here now I want to
briefly attract your attention to the to
the to the architecture of the platform
now those of you who have seen security
information event management tools or
log management tools may recognize some
of the components I wanted to point at
some things that are different now for
the same tools that we built in the 90s
or in the early 2000s threat detection
an incident investigation and of course
a few other use cases were central
threat hunting however was not Chronicle
is one of the few Sims built with threat
hunting as a first-class use case for a
platform it's kind of a group of use
cases rather not just one use case so to
me the ability to search and rapidly
pivot and refine signals while you're
doing while you're pursuing a pretty
subtle or a thin indicator of an attack
is important and I don't want to just
rely on search or on reports or on rule
based detection for doing that I want my
interactive and pivoting search platform
that's instant there are a few other
things that are interesting here
Chronicle makes certain types of
telemetry like DNS and DHCP logs to also
be a first-class data source now I've
dealt with Sims for at this point for
almost 20 years for 18 years to me to be
exact and at this point I seen people
not
with DNS not put DHCP logs not put file
hashes in their sims because they just
overwhelmed in case of Chronicle you
would want to put this data in and it
would not cost you anything I'll get to
the question point in a second of course
today's security operations is
unthinkable without heavy reliance of
threat intelligence in case of Chronicle
you would have if you have your own
threat Intel you have public sources
some of them are more noisier than
others
all these threat Intel data flows into
the platform without any challenges and
it will be cross correlated to logs in a
few ways I will explain it in the next
slide now this slide is probably more
useful to people who have dealt with
threat detection security monitoring
threat investigation challenges and or
deployed similar tools I wanted to hit a
few points here some in more detail than
others first even though I'm a
technologist I want to start with
disruptive economics now what does the
certificate omics really mean today it
means a pricing model for a security
monitoring tool that's different now
some of you are used to seeing tools
that deploy and price based on data
volume collected or the number of data
sources the number of log sources or on
the number of components deployed there
is a lot of complexity and of course
there's also a charge for data retention
if you're storing data for a year for
example so Chronicle launched with a
pricing model that runs of the number of
employees people not data sources not
data points not events per second now
this means that you have fully
predictable pricing and predictable just
means if you're a large company you
count your employees and that's the
price now this is incredibly liberating
I let me tell you that for a security
solution the reason for that is that a
lot of tools are prized by data volume
or some derivative of that and that
means you have to balance your security
requirements with the fear that you
would overrun the license you didn't cut
costs and in case of Chronicle you kind
of pay a fixed price per year and by the
way that fixed price includes one year
of log retention not 30 days
not 90 days not 180 days a full year and
you can pay the same and you get a data
retain for more than that
and to me this is also an important
point now keeping data for a year isn't
that hard it's expensive for some other
people but it's not hard
now how much searching across terabyte
of data and sub-second speed I'm gonna
move into the bottom item on the slide
admittedly very few people at Google are
impressed by search speed because hey
Google can search Internet at the same
speed now in the security operations
threat detection space instantaneous
searches over petabytes of data just
aren't that common or in fact if they do
happen to somebody it's usually at the
cost of hardware measured in millions
and not tens of millions Chronicle is
built in a way that it can search
structured data in under a second over
any volume of data and we really mean
that to me when I first learned that it
was a huge huge innovation even though
again the team that presented to me the
chronical team at the time didn't really
act as if it's a big deal of course
they're from Google now to me being able
to search a terabyte of data at
sub-second speed dozen table a lot of
investigative hunting and detection use
cases in a very clean way let me hit a
few more points on the slide and I'm
gonna go into details on on two of them
we also noticed that in the past with
tools that collect the data but don't
make it useful the quality of data
inside a security monitoring platform is
a big challenge we decided to focus very
heavily on having clean enriched cross
correlated data and our platform here on
the slide is highlighted as intelligent
data fusion that means we can collect
the data and we can make it useful for
security operation use cases by
connecting different data pieces
firewall data connected to EGR des that
connected to server data connected to
other data sources new collection of
course the DNS and DHCP as I highlighted
we can also use this in rich data to
cross correlate with threat intelligence
and they can do that both historically
and in real-time I'm gonna make another
point about this in in the next slide
also we decided to build a detection
engine into this platform that
and detect threats that are modern that
appeared today of course we would cover
the popular threats on that slide but
you also want to be future proof so if
new types of threats appear we will be
able to write detection content to catch
them
of course self managed is a no-brainer
here because it comes with the cloud
model chronically after all is a SAS
platform so in that sense we don't
suffer from some of the complexities of
an crema since that's an obvious point
how do customers use it I want to
highlight this very briefly because in
many regards we are deployed to extend
another solution you may have a tool
that you use for compliance reporting
for certain types of your flow but
you're not handling the volume well we
do see Chronicle deployed with other
tools to enhance this of course we also
see situations where Chronicle is
deployed as their sim as the main
security information event management
tool for their stock for their security
operations team and in this case they
migrate from historical sim to our
platform in the middle you see another
scenario in this case we do see
customers deploy Chronicle to on top of
EDR there are some popular EDR solutions
that produce telemetry that's very
useful for threat detection
investigation but they don't actually
detain it for a year now you can refer
to some of the writing we have done the
Chronicle website about how this is
valuable I want to highlight the fact
that if you are investigating there is
nothing better than having super quick
access to one year of data or more than
that now one thing I mentioned briefly
is detection and one of the big
surprises for me when I first
encountered Chronicle technology was
that Chronicle relied a lot on threat
intelligence and rules rather than say
machine learning as some other vendors
now we do think that machine learning is
a good approach for detection however we
also think that for machine learning to
work well you have to learn from
something from real-world experiences of
hunters instant responders and not just
from the vendor labs so we are we've
deployed Chronicle with the rule based
detection with Intel based detection
that covers terabytes can run on very
high quality and rich data that we have
so we can match to enrich data say IP
addresses or DNS names even if threat
indicators don't natural dating we also
have a way to write detection logic
that's not about writing queries but
about writing detection writing
detections here means writing focused
use cases to detect threats not just
extract data and then think what it
means this to me is kind of a big deal
yara l is our approach to this and you
can see the white paper on the site
there's a lot of content written on the
RAL and how its evolving I did want to
very briefly remind you about the
productivity that stands from sub-second
responses for search again my first
encounter with the platform highlighted
that if you have tens of gigabytes of
data hundreds of gigs or petabytes the
search speed would be the same and that
does allow you to run queries run
detection logic that is not constrained
by performance this to me is a very big
point I don't want my sock to be in a
performance optimization business I want
them to be in security business threat
detection business not in oh my god my
sim is too slow business I want them to
run detection logic instantly and
Chronicle has enabled that now as a
technologist I am probably more inclined
to talk about features advantages
capabilities detection logic but for
Chronicle disruptive economics is kind
of a big part of the attraction of the
platform to me nobody was able to build
a software service monitoring platform a
threat detection platform that does not
rely on any volume pricing on data
admittedly some of the advantages you
see here I inherent with any SAS tools
no infrastructure setup costs and circle
rapid searches but things like all the
data you want collected at a fixed cost
is unique and to me this eliminates many
of the challenges of modern Sox face you
want to have more data have more data
that's a decision that should be based
on the merits and not on the costs this
to me is what's changing the landscape
of some of the stock operations that
I've encountered where you can include
the data sources you want EDR deeper
service server telemetry
some of the cloud cloud data sources and
not pay anything for any extra sources
is hugely liberating now if you're
planning the deployment of our tool of
Chronicle it's useful to highlight a few
items when you're doing this now we do
have tools to support total cost of
ownership analysis I mean admittedly
most vendors do that but what you would
see in our case is that many of the TCO
calculations many other TCO arguments
because they derive their magic from the
predictable price and decoupled from
capacity compute number of things you
run so to me this is a very big part of
an attraction as I pointed out and again
some of the things you see on this slide
are character are characteristics of all
modern tools like for example it relies
on api's but some things on that slide
are very uniquely Google of course we de
Lyonne some of the threat and tell that
stems from Google's research and
Google's teams that focus on identifying
threat actors but we also highlight
things like a rapid delivery model deep
rapid deployment and of course
sub-second searches over any source of
data to me many of the clients and
prospects who are looking at Chronicle
have evaluated things similar to those
in the slide and decided to go with the
platform let's get to the final part of
the presentation namely the action items
I would hypothesize that many of the
listeners have some form of security
information event management tool or a
log management tool where they open
source commercial where the software is
service or impairments now one thing to
note is that if your approach today is
heavily on premise based I think the
time is coming to evaluate it now I
would not pretend that Chronicle is the
only tool there's maybe a set of half a
dozen approaches half a dozen tools then
there's that started to build software
service same software service threat
detection tools back in my analyst days
I've looked at them and I found some of
the promising some of them are not
promising the idea is that the on
premise approach starts to slowly lose
the importance and I would say if I'm
planning my threat detection platform of
the future it would probably be soft
service it would not be a legacy tool
deployed on I ass it would not be a
legacy still deployment premise it would
be a native SAS tool
advantages and the future-proof nosov
such tool if I may call it coin the term
here
I just unmatched now you may think the
deploying SAS based software service
based tools is make sense make sense for
cloud environments and you would direct
however my point is that it's also
useful for in premise deep environments
some of the advantages of SAS lack of
maintenance management performance
tuning much faster content updates much
much more rapid deployment of detection
rule normalization other types of
advantages are there and their inherent
in SAS in case of Chronicle they are
coupled with super rapid speed backwards
and forward indicator matching and of
course our unique to a detection
language now I did mention that
Chronicle is a software service platform
and I mentioned some of the advantages
of SAS platforms for monitoring in
threat detection
now there would be of still a large
group of organizations it would prefer
some help
even with SAS now as I said with SAS you
don't need the mode to operate the
server's performance tune but you still
need to do things associated with a
typical security operations workflow
respond to alerts respond to incidents
perform threat hunting what what's
useful to note is the Chronicle enables
a decent number of managed security
providers of MDR providers or managed
detection response and those providers
do take the last mile may help you with
alerts they help you with defining what
type of detection to do they help you
with figure out what threats you need to
add to the list of the popular threats
which threats are focused on your
business
so to me the value of Chronicle for
managed security providers is also huge
because of the cost model because of the
detection content so to me the useful
thing to keep in mind is that if your
company thinks is not ready for
deploying this I personally doubt it but
if you are in a bucket you can find a
managed security services provider an
MDR provider that runs Chronicles you
gain many of the advantages of the
platform but you'd also get help with
writing with your sock right in your
storage operations
now to conclude I wanted to highlight
the fact that Chronicle remains a
growing platform the product is it's
very young so there would be things that
we'll have to build we are still
building the York flow system we are
still building a few other things around
detection and of course we want to make
our detection smarter by using machine
learning and AI techniques the idea here
is that we have unique and strong
advantages in the platform that I
highlighted but you also remain to be a
gherkin progress to a large extent as
every good product is frankly so to me
what we invite you to do is not just to
make use of Chronicle today but to also
grow with us thank you very much for
listening